[Musique]
je vous posais une question pour
commencer est ce que vous savez en sa
naissance son espérance de vie en 1875
j'ai entendu la bonne réponse 45 ans
effectivement c'est 45 ans alors la
question que je me suis posée c'est
qu'est-ce qui fait un tel décalage entre
son espérance de vie à la naissance et
le fait de vivre plus de 120 ans alors
quand on regarde l'espérance de vie et
son évolution depuis 1750 on voit une
augmentation linéaire et constante
en fait depuis plus de 250 ans
l'espérance de vie augmente de trois
mois par an alors je me posais la
question qu'est ce qui pouvait être
qu'elle fait vous pouvez bien justifier
une telle augmentation de l'espérance de
vie
pendant toute cette cette période
importante
est-ce que vous avez un point de vue là
dessus est ce que vous pouvez me dire la
génétique alimentation hygiène de vie
on les a presque tous alors pour la
génétique pour jeanne calment sûrement
mais à l'échelle d'une population peut
pas imaginer que la génétique soit le
facteur prépondérant donc naturellement
l'hygiène est un facteur prépondérant le
fait de pouvoir limiter la propagation
des maladies
le deuxième point c'est naturellement la
prise en charge de la santé la médecine
et le fait de pouvoir développer des
nouveaux médicaments
mais justement les médicaments ce que
j'ai observé en regardant la courbe
c'est que le prix d'un médicament
augmente de plus en plus et aujourd'hui
je sais pas si vous êtes au courant mais
développer un nouveau médicament
ça coûte plus d'un milliard d'euros
et c'est pour ça la conséquence que
beaucoup de maladies en fait sont encore
non traités et non pas de traitement
valide
je pense particulièrement à la maladie
d'alzheimer ou également aux 8000
maladies rares ou là il ya presque aucun
développement de médicaments qui a
réalisé
alors je me suis posé également la
question de comment on pouvait changer
ça comment on pouvait accélérer et donc
j'ai regardé un petit peu comment on
teste un médicament avant de le tester
sur le corps humain alors la première
étape c'est de prendre une cellule une
cellule humaine la mettre dans une
espèce de boîte de plastique plate et de
tester une drogue de tester un
médicament alors l'enjeu c'est de
regarder l'efficacité et la toxicité du
médicament alors forcément les boîtes en
plastique ça représente pas vraiment le
corps humain mais ça nous donne déjà une
première
une première vision la deuxième étape
eh ben c'est d'aller vers une échelle
plus complexes et de regarder au niveau
d'un organisme complet et notamment le
modèle animal malheureusement lorsque
ces molécules sont validées sur les
animaux lorsqu'elles ont passé ces
premiers tests d'efficacité toxicité eh
ben elle échoue à 90%
quand on passe sur le corps humain
je vous laisse imaginer si 90% des
missions spatiales était abandonné juste
après le décollage
alors je me suis reposé la question
vu la faible efficacité vu le coût de
développement d'un médicament
pourquoi on utilise encore le modèle
animal et bien tout simplement parce
qu'on n'a pas trouvé mieux
alors
j'ai regardé un petit peu autour de moi
dans la littérature pas dans la science
fiction mais plutôt dans la littérature
scientifique
s'il n'y avait pas des pistes savait pas
quand même des solutions si les pas des
choses qui étaient faites
et en fait il ya plein de pistes il ya
plein de choses et donc ce que j'ai
décidée c'est de passer une bonne partie
de ma vie à développer ses solutions
alors ces solutions elles s'appellent
les organes sur puce je vais essayer de
vous expliquer mais d'abord on va
essayer de changer d'échelle
on va passer à l'échelle micrométrique
tout à l'heure je vous les ai parlé on
mettait des cellules humaines dans des
boîtes plate et qu'on les cultiver eh
bien les organes sur puce en fait on va
utiliser des cellules humaines
mais on va les mettre dans des
structures qui s'appelle des petites
puces à l'échelle micrométrique qui vont
simuler la forme et la fonction d'un
organe on va faire un zoom pour vous
compreniez exactement imaginez une
cellules pulmonaires dans une alvéole
pulmonaire d'un côté il ya du sang et
c'est ce que vous voyez en rouge donc il
ya du sang et la vascularisation qui se
fait juste en dessous il ya un tapis
cellulaire encore en dessous en bleu il
ya d'autres cellules et sur l'apa la
partie inférieure il ya de l'oxygène
donc l'idée des organes sur plus c'est
d'imiter ce que ville corps humain dans
un dispositif miniaturisés alors bien
sûr on fabrique pas un organe complet
c'est juste une partie en fait et ça
l'objectif c'est que ça prédisent mieux
la réponse qui aura sur le corps humain
c'est d'avoir des meilleurs modèles
un des exemples qu'on développe en ce
moment
typiquement c'est un cancer du rein sur
puce alors on met des cellules
cancéreuses de rein et on va tester une
molécule et on va pouvoir voir
l'évolution du cancer en temps réel une
des autres activités qu'on développe
c'est l'interconnexion de plusieurs
organes l'idée un peu comme avec le rat
c'est d'avoir un organisme plus complexe
donc on peut imaginer prendre
une cellule de coeur une cellule de rein
une cellule de foi et regarder si un
développement de métastases par exemple
où l'impact de telles molécules ou tel
médicament sur les autres organes un
dernier projet qu'on développe également
chez nous c'est le fait de pouvoir
mettre vos cellules dans ces petits
dispositifs miniaturisés l'idée c'est
que si vous êtes malade bien sûr votre
génétique est différente des autres donc
un médicament peut pas avoir la même
efficacité sur chaque personne donc
l'idée c'est que si on peut utiliser vos
cellules on va pouvoir développer le
médicament à façon c'est ce qu'on
appelle la médecine personnalisée et
donc c'est grâce à cette technologie
qu'on pense pouvoir faire accélérer le
développement de médicaments et qui sait
peut-être comme jeanne calment commencer
les scream
à 85 ans je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]